linear regression in our my name is
Richard Kirchner with the simply learned
team that's w w simply learned comm get
certified get ahead what's in it for you
we'll start with covering why linear
regression what is linear regression how
linear regression works and then finally
we'll dive into the use case predicting
the revenue using linear regression and
we'll be in the our platform for this
today let's dive into why linear
regression now that we have come this
far I'm planning to take a closer look
at ourselves so that we can estimate
cells in the future how about we hire a
data scientist you can see our to
corporate individuals looks more like
they should be agents or secret agents
someplace discussing how to better
forward their company and so they're
gonna come in a NASA data science just
to come in good idea this will help us
to keep a constant track of ourselves so
why do we need linear regression let's
assume that we need to predict the
number of skiers based on snowfall so
this happens to be we've kind of jump
one business to the next so we're
looking at the skiing business very
popular in a lot of areas and it's based
on snowfall a lot of times you figure
you don't have snow you don't have
skiers but can we actually use something
more specific instead of luck at snowing
and instead of saying hey look it's
snowing we can actually start drawing
graphs and the graph shows that with an
increase in snowfall the frequency of
skiers also increases so and there's a
pretty direct correlation if you've ever
been up to ski areas when there's a lot
of snow falls the skiers all shut
because they know it's gonna be better
skiing right afterwards so it's kind of
easy to see why skiers and snowfall
would go together and usually draws a
nice straight line and you can easily
predict how many skiers and that way you
can also predict how many people you
need to service them how many lifts to
have up and running and all the stuff
that goes with running a ski area thus
we see that the number of skiers are
directly proportional to the amount of
snow fall regression models a relation
between a dependent y and an independent
X variable this is real important
understand regression because we talk
about linear regression it's the basis
of almost all our machine learning
algorithms out there and it's usually an
underlying part of the math in our deep
learning so it all starts here with
linear regression
and we talk about a dependent Y and an
independent X variable these are numbers
we're usually talking about floats so we
want to have an actual number value
coming out and that's different than
something that's categorical or we want
to know yes or no true/false so
regression means we're looking for a
number the independent variable is known
as predictor variable and dependent
variable is known as the response
variable so we have one predictor
variable the amount of snowfall and one
response variable
how many skiers are going to show up and
then we can take this relationship and
it can be expressed as y equals beta
we're going to use a Greek letter beta
and we have beta naught plus beta 1 X 1
and if you continue added B plus beta 2
X 2 and so on till the nth degree in
this case snowfall is an independent
variable and skiers is a dependent
variable so we kind of had a little
quick overview let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about what is linear
regression so we're gonna go from Y
predicting number of skiers for snowfall
and we've looked at the formula bit but
let's look a bit closer at what exactly
is going on with linear regression and
the question is gonna come up in an
interview what is linear regression
linear regression is a type of
statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between two
variables linear regression creates a
predictive model on any data showing
trends and data the model is found by
using the least square method there are
other methods the least square method
happens to be the most commonly used out
there and we usually start with the
least square method since it's the most
common and usually works the best on
most models and we're already looking at
how linear regression works but let's
dig deeper into it and let's take a
closer look how linear regression works
I will provide you with a data set which
has rent area other information in it it
looks like our secret agents have put on
their casual wear for this one you need
to predict rent accordingly we are given
area and rent here so you can do linear
regression with more variables but we're
just gonna look at the area and then
from that try to figure out what the
rent should be we plot the graph and if
you look at it here you can see that the
graph kind of a linear pattern with a
little dip in it so the area seems to
the rent seems to be based on the air
yeah in most of our work as data
scientists we usually try to start with
a physical graph if we can so we can
actually look at it and say hey does
what I'm fitting to this graph look
right you can solve a lot of problems
that arise by looking at the graph and
saying no that doesn't look right at all
or I should be looking over here for
this then we find the mean of area and
rent so the mean just means average and
if you take one two three four five and
add them all together and divide by in
this case there's five areas you get
three and the rent is two four six five
and eight if you add them all together
and divide by 5 you get five and we plot
the mean on the graph so you can see
right here here's the mean of the rent
and the area it's kind of a very central
point which is what we're looking for
the average of everything in there the
best fit line passes through the mean
this is real important when you're
eyeballing it as humans we can do this
fairly easy if it's a straight line
through a bunch of data it gets more
complicated mathematically when you
start adding multiple variables and
instead of a line you have occur but for
basic linear regression we're gonna draw
a line through the data and the line
should go through the means that's gonna
be part of the best fit for that line
but we see there are multiple lines that
can pass through the means so depending
on how you look at it you can kind of
wiggle the line around back and forth so
we keep moving the line to ensure that
the best fit line has the least squared
distance from the data points and this
is you can see right here residual we
have our data point and then we look at
this distance between them and we square
that distance and that's what they mean
by the least squared distance we want
all those distances to add up to the
smallest amount we can we talk about
that distance we call it the residual it
equals the Y actual minus the Y
predicted very straightforward just
looking at the distance you can
accidentally switch these and it'll come
out the same because we're going to
square it but when you're working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the Y actual minus
the y predicted the value of M and C for
the best fit line y equals MX plus C can
be calculated using the mention formula
and you can see here we have M equals
the number of points that's what n
stands for then we have the Sigma the
Greek symbol is there which is a
summation of x times y minus the
summation of x times the summation of y
over the number of the summation of x
squared minus the summation of x squared
of X all of it squared I can be a little
confusing trying to say that and then of
course your C value is going to be the
summation of Y times the summation of x
squared minus the summation of x times
the summation of x times y over the
total count of the summation x squared
minus the summation of x squared that's
a mouthful normally we don't worry too
much about these formulas other than to
know they're there now if you're a
mathematician you might go back in there
and work on those and those people who
originally started to put together the
different models in our of course had to
know all this math to build them and had
to test it out that's when the nice
things about our what is important is
that you know about these formulas so
that you know where it's coming from so
if you're using one linear regression
model this is how this one works there's
other linear regression models based on
different math and so you have to be
aware when that math changes and how
that changes the model we find the
corresponding values so in this case if
you're going to break this up and you're
building your own model instead of using
the 1 in are you would have your rent
you would have your area you would find
your rent squared your area squared and
your rent times area and if we go back 1
we can see that that's all the different
little pieces in this model we have x
times y we have x squared we have the
sum of X which is going to be squared we
have the sum of X the sum of Y this is
the same these are all the little pieces
in here that we see for M equals and C
equals and so once we compute all these
we have 15 25 55 145 88 very easy to do
on a computer thankfully you could have
millions of these points and it would do
it in a very short period we can then
plug in those values very easily into
this formula and get a final answer and
we'll see the M equals one point three
and C equals one point one and then when
we take this for the Y predicted equals
M of I X of I plus C we can take these
and actually run the data we have so
we're gonna see how it predicts so now
we find the y the value of y predicted
so we have our X N and we want to know
what Y what we think Y will be based on
our formula we generated the linear
regression formula and so we come in
here we have our X
our actual why then we have our why
predict what we think it's going to be
and then we have we take why - why
predict and we get those values - 0.4
it's off by 0.3 this one's off by 1 this
one's on off by - 1.3 by 0.4 and we go
ahead and square that and then we can
sum that Square and average it out and
we'll get a value this is just a
summation down here why - why predicted
square is 3.1 and we call that the least
square value for this line is 3.1 and we
go ahead and divide that by 5 so when we
plot the Y predict and this is the best
fit line and you can see that there's a
pretty good job going right through the
middle of lines and in something like
rent versus area if you're trying to
figure out how much rent to charge or
how many people are allowed to be in the
area that's gonna work but if you're
looking for the rent value compared to
the area this gives you a good idea
based on the area of what you should
rent the place for it's close enough
that in the business world this would
work
you're not computing something down to
the millimeters or micrometers or
nuclear physics
we're just charging people and so if
you're off by a couple of dollars it's
not a big deal you'll be pretty close to
what you think it's worth and get the
right value for your property use case
predicting the revenue using linear
regression now that you have a good idea
of how linear regression works and we're
kicking back on our lounging sofa today
let's work on a real-life scenario where
you have to predict the revenue so we're
gonna take a data set and we'll pull
this up in just a minute we'll have paid
organic social and revenue there are
three attributes we'll be working on the
first one is our paid traffic so all the
traffic through the advertisement that
comes in the non paid traffic from
search engines so these are people
coming to the website and are doing so
because they did a search for something
specific so it's pulling it from your
website all the traffic coming from
social networking sites so we want to
know what's coming from Twitter and
Facebook and somehow they've linked into
your website and coming into your
marketing area to buy something and
we'll use this to predict the revenue so
we want to know how all this traffic
comes together and how it's going to
affect our sells if the traffic's coming
in we're gonna make use of the multiple
linear regression model so you'll see
that this is very similar that we had
before where we had y equals m times
x plus c but instead we have y equals M
1 X 1 plus M 2 X 2 plus M 3 X 3 plus C M
is the slope
so you have M 1 M 2 M 3 the three
different slopes of three different
lines y is the revenue so we're only
looking for one variable and remember
this is regression so we're looking for
a number x1 is gonna be the paid traffic
and of course m1 the corresponding slope
x2 the organic traffic and x3 the social
traffic we will follow these steps to
create the regression model
we'll start by generating inputs using
the CSV files
well then import the libraries splitting
the data into train and test very
important whenever you're doing any kind
of data science applying regression on
paid traffic organic traffic social
traffic so we're gonna apply a
regression model on them and then we're
gonna validate the model as a whole
reason we split it to a training and
testing it so we can now validate to see
just how good our model is now before we
open up our I always like to just take a
quick look at the data itself and we're
using the Rev CSV file and this is a
does CEA's file or a comma separated
variable file we'll just open that with
WordPad any kind of text editor would be
nice to show you what's going on and you
can see we have paid organic social and
revenue across the top so your titles
for your columns and the values going
down and this is the same as what we saw
on the slide just a minute ago paid
organic social and the revenue from them
they probably have it in more of a
spreadsheet than just a word pad and I'm
using the newer version of our studio
which already has a nice layout
automatically opens up with your console
and terminal window down and left you
have your script and will run it in
script and then when I run it line by
line in script you'll see a show up on
the console bottom left I could type it
straight into the console and it would
do the same thing and then on the right
we have our environment and under the
environment we'll see
plots if you're in an older version the
plots will pop up and you usually are
running just in the console and then you
have to open up a different window to
run the script and you can run the
script from there this opens up
everything at the same time when you use
the new our studio setup and the first
thing you want to do is we want to go
ahead and generate a variable we'll call
it cells and we want to load this with
our data set and so in
are we use the less than minus sign
that's the same as a sign - it's like an
arrow pointing at cells and says
whatever it goes past here is gonna be
assigned to cells we want to read in our
CSV file and then I went ahead and fixed
the CSV file up a little bit when I say
the CSV file I mean the path to it we'll
go ahead and paste that in there and
this is my edited version and you'll see
I took wherever we had the backward
slash I switched it for a forward slash
because a backward slash is an escape
character and whenever you're
programming in just about any scripting
language you want to do the forward
slash instead so like a good chef I
prepped this and copied it into my
clipboard and we can see the full path
here and the full path ends in our re v
dot CSV files that's the path on my
machine and then I'm gonna run that and
now we have down here you see lit appear
right here I almost have an error in my
path it says object Rev not found let me
fix that real quick
and run it again and this time it does
assign the cells the data set and then
we'll just type in cells and this is the
same as printing it so if you work in
other languages you'll do like print and
then cells or maybe print cells ahead if
you're in pandas and Python or something
like that but in R you just type in the
variable will run this and you can see
it printed out all those columns so
that's the same thing we just looked at
and it says max print so it emitted 750
rows there so as a total of a thousand
rows and we can scroll up here on our
console where the answer came in and if
I screw up to the top way up to the top
there we go you'll see paid organic
social and revenue so everything looks
good on this and there's a lot of cool
things we can do with it one of the
things we can do is Aiken summary it so
let's do a summary of cells and we'll
run that and the summary of cells comes
in and tells you your men first quarter
median mean third quarter max
for paid organic social bricks it up and
you can actually get kind of a quick
view as to what the data is doing you
can take more time to study this a lot
of people look at this and you can see
from the median the mean that tells you
a lot and it's divided into quarters so
you have your first quarter value and
your third quarter set up on there and
max it just gives you a quick idea
what's going on in the data summary is a
really wonderful tool one of the reasons
I like to jump in
to our before I might do a major project
in something else or you can run
everything enough and let's take a look
at the head head of cells and let me run
this and you can see it shows ahead of
our data the first six rows in this case
and it starts with one important to know
other different systems start with zero
and go up our is one that starts with
the first is one and then if we want to
do a plot I'll go ahead and do a plot
cells another really powerful tool that
you can just jump right into with our
one save your data in here and you'll
see that the plot comes over on the
right hand side and what it does is it
compares them so if I look at my paid a
my organic and you cross it to you'll
see there's a nice line down the middle
big black line where plus the two
together let me just widen this a little
bit so we can see more of it there we go
the same thing with paid and social paid
and revenue so each one of these has a
clearer connection to each other so
that's a good sign we have a nice
correlation between the data and you can
just eyeball that that's a good way to
jump in and explore your data rather
quickly and see what's going on so we'll
go ahead and I'll put a count sign there
a hashtag and splitting the data into
training and test data and we want to
split it so that we have something to
work with to train our data set and when
we do our data set you do this with any
data set cuz you want to make sure you
have a good model and then once we've
trained it we're going to take the other
set of data we'd pulled off to the side
and we'll test it to see how good it is
if you test it with the training data
that it's already got that memorized and
shouldn't give you a really good answer
in fact when you get into more advanced
machine learning tools you watch those
very closely you watch your training set
and how it does versus your testing set
and if your training set starts doing
better than your testing set then you're
starting to over train it now that's
more with deep learning and some other
packages that are beyond what we're
working with today but yeah this is
important it's very important to
understand that that test and that
training correlate with each other and
gives you an idea what's going on and
make sure that you're set up correctly
and we'll go ahead and set a seed of two
and that's for our random generators so
that when we run them you can see them
with just a rat there's a ways to
randomize a number or you can do like
date and stuff like that but that way we
always use the same
numbers so we'll see it it with two and
then we're gonna need a library in this
case we're gonna import the library and
we want to import CA tools and CA tools
how's our split function so we're gonna
be able to split our data along with
many other tools we're going to need for
this example so they're all built into
the CA tools that's what we need to
import that the life times they call
them library or syndrome referred to as
packages so let's go ahead and run that
line and that brings a library in so now
we can use all those different tools
that are in there and then I'm gonna do
a split and we're going to assign to the
split that's going to be our variable
sample split okay so that's one of the
tools we just brought in is to sample as
the actual keyword or the function where
it sample dot split and we're going to
take our cells and we're gonna go ahead
and with split ratio equals two point
seven and this to zero point seven so we
make sure it knows it's a decimal point
or float and what this is saying is that
we're going to take our cells data the
variable we created called cells it has
a data in there and I want to split it
and I'm gonna split it so that 70% of it
goes in one side we'll use that for
training and 30% will go into the other
side which we'll use then for testing
out our model let me go ahead and run
that and let's hold on one second got an
error there spit it's definitely very
different than split I don't think we
want to spit our data out we which is
actually kind of what we're doing and
spitting it out but we want a split
we're gonna split the data something get
that spelled correctly i think when i
type in split we can just run that
because that's now a variable you'll see
that it has true false false true so it
generates a number of interesting
different statistics going across there
as far as the way it splits the data and
right here if you have not used our in a
while or if you're new to our completely
that line one that's what that little
one means down there and then true false
false true that means that's how we're
looking at the data we're splitting all
those different pieces of data in line
one different directions and so we now
want to create our train set and we're
going to assign that and when we taken
away sign to the train set a subset of
cells and then the subset of cells
that's going to be based on split equal
put this in brackets true so you can see
the values down here is capital T
capital R capital u capital e so I just
wanna reflect that on the train and this
is going to take everything where our
split variable is equal to true and it's
going to set cells equal to that and
we'll go ahead and run that and then
we're going to set our test variable as
a subset of cells and if we assign the
true to the train set then we want to
assign the false to our test set so now
we'll have this we'll have 30% of the
variables in it and train will have 70%
go ahead and run that so we've now
created both our training set and our
test set and we can just real quickly
type in train get the run on there and
you can see our train set if we scroll
way up to the top I'll have the column
names on there which should match what
we had before paid organic social and
revenue and then we'll type in test when
I hit run on there that's going to do
the same thing you'll spit out all the
test variables going out so now that we
have the test and train variables we
want to go ahead and create the model
and you'll see this in any of the
machine learning tutorials they always
refer to them as models we're modeling a
function of some kind on the data to fit
the data and then we're going to put the
test data through there to see how well
it does and so we're gonna create the
variable called models and I'm going to
assign that LM that is our linear
regression model
I love how simplified R makes it just LM
linear regression and then model M I
guess it dates back because the linear
regression model is like one of the
first major models used so they kept it
easy on there and revenue happens to be
the main variable that we want to track
so if you remember quickly from our
formula Y is the revenue and then we
have X as our paid traffic x2 organic
traffic and x3 are social traffic so Y
is what we want to predict in here and
then you'll see this notation where we
have our squiggle and the period which
means we're going to match up the
revenue lines with the lines of the data
we're putting in here and then I'll put
comma and then our data equals train and
of course that's the training data that
we creative so when I hit the Run
remember we did all that discussion
about all those different functions and
formulas to compute our model and how
that set up when it comes down to it we
spend all our time setting up our data
and then we hit the run button on the
single line and our models been trained
so we now have a trained model here and
we can do a summary of the model summary
is such a wonderful command because you
can do that on our that works on all
kinds of different things on there oops
and of course it does help if I remember
that my model has a capital n when I run
it and you'll see right here it tells
you a little bit about the model use the
summary on there comes down here has our
residuals this is all the information on
there as far as like the minimum the
median the Max has all our coefficients
in there if you remember quickly from
our formula let's just go ahead and
switch back over to that we have M 1 X 1
M 2 X 2 M 3 X 3 plus C well that's right
here we here's our intercept and then we
have our different values for each of
these so you have our intercept or paid
organic and social and then it also
shows us error in information on the
error and but the really nice things
about when you're working with our you
can come down here and you see where we
have our stars down here and it says
three stars really good two stars maybe
one star probably no correlation and we
can see with all of these it has three
stars on them so out of three stars we
get three stars on all of these there's
no four stars four stars would mean that
you have the exact same data going in as
coming out and then if we're gonna do
this we won't actually run a prediction
on here and that's what we saved our
test data for so let's come down here
we'll do our prediction we'll take this
variable and we'll assign it predict
model remember the predict comes from
and we imported that package the CA
tools that's all part of the CA tools in
there so we're going to predict we're
gonna use a model and then we're gonna
use our test data pretty straightforward
quick and easy we'll run this and then
if we go ahead and type in the predict
you'll print out what's in that variable
and you'll see down here the predicted
values expects to come out it's gonna
see our revenue is and it goes through
and it gives it both the line number and
the actual revenue value so that's quick
and easy boy we got a prediction really
fast and this is also how you would do
it if you had new data coming in after
this you could predict the revenue based
on these other factors so now that we
have a training model which or we train
the data with our
training data or we trained the model
with our training data and we've done a
prediction on our model with our test
data we wouldn't look this up and we
took a quick glance from our training
thing our training said it trained
really well but that's not the final
word on it the final word is going to be
comparing it so we want to go ahead and
do comparing predicted versus actual
values what I'm going to do is I'm going
to do a plot and I'm going to do our
test and we're going to do test revenue
dot type equals and we can put this in
as a type type one and orell and then we
have LT y equals 1.8 and we're gonna set
it for column blue that's a lot of stuff
in there let's go ahead and just run
that so we can see what that looks like
and what's that's doing it's gonna
generate this nice graph we see on the
right there's our graph you can see the
data comes up and down I'll be plotting
the prediction on there so this is the
values we predicted let's go ahead and
do lines and I actually did this
backwards so let me try that again
and we'll start with the red one we're
gonna do the first one in red and I want
to start with the actual test revenue so
here's our test revenue and we'll go
ahead and run this and so we have a red
plot over here in red go ahead and take
a look at that and pull that over you
can see how that looks
goes up and down hard to track there and
then we're gonna do a couple things here
we'll plot our test revenue
and they will make it little pretty of
those kind of hard to say see the way I
have is scrunched up here on the right
as far as size and sizing everything but
we'll go ahead and have our columns in
blue and run our prediction on there too
you see the overlap the two graphs so we
have our test revenue and our prediction
and then finally what I started with is
we'll go ahead and plot the prediction
fully on the bottom and run that if you
look over here on the graph we put the
blue lines over the red lines and so
you'll see a couple spots where there's
red underneath there but for the most
part our prediction is pretty right on
so it looks really tight looks like a
good set of predictions for what we're
working on and this is what we were
looking at the slide right before we
started diving into the our studio we
can see in the slide here here's a red
that's a little bit better spread out
than what I have on my screen from where
our studio and the graph shows the
predicted revenue we see that the two
lines are very close so again they're
tight it's right on this is what we're
looking for in our prediction model but
it's not good enough just having a graph
and you always do both and the reason we
do both is you want to have a visual of
it because sometimes you look at these
you get to the graph you're like oh my
gosh what is that and then sometimes you
look at the graphic oh that's right on
how come my accuracy doesn't look right
and you realize that your accuracy might
be off or you're plotting it incorrectly
so let's go ahead and look up the
accuracy and we'll use our MSE that's
gonna be the variable name we're gonna
give it and the SKU RT the square root
of the mean and mean just means average
and then we want prediction - sales
revenue and then we're going to take
this whole thing and we're going to
square it
so what we've got here is we're gonna go
through let's just explain this formula
we're using is I'm gonna look at the
what I predict it for to be and what the
actual sales what's our prediction
versus our sales comparison to the
revenue and we compare those two we're
gonna find the average and then I'm
going or we're going to square each one
of those values and then we're gonna
average the square and then find the
square root of that and that's quite a
mouthful the reason we do it this way
the reason we square the value and then
we find the means is to generate an
answer based on doesn't matter whether
it's plus or minus there's a lot of
other formulas you can use there to
check your accuracy and all kinds of
things you can do but a quick
straightforward way of doing it is just
like this and then let's go ahead and
run this and then we type in the rmse
and they'll give us an actual printed
value out let's just see what that looks
like and so we have eight sixty six
point six three three eight for our
accuracy so we look at the 866 point six
three and we compare that to say 50,000
that's pretty close that's actually a
pretty good accuracy given this model
takes a little bit more when you're
playing with accuracies and start
dividing out other different aspects of
it to get something you can communicate
better with but you always start with
the square root means that's always a
good place to start so what are the key
takeaways for this why linear regression
regression models a relationship between
dependency Y and an independent X
variable the independent variable is
known as a predictor variable and the
dependent variable is known as the
response variable the relationship can
be expressed as y equals beta naught
plus beta 1 X 1 plus beta 2 X 2 etc and
we looked at what linear regression is
linear regression is a type of
statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between two
variables linear regression creates a
productive model and any data showing
trends and data the model is found by
using the least square method and then
we looked at how linear regression works
we plot the Y predict and this is the
best fit line whatever's gonna have the
minimal error on it and a use case to
predict the revenue we looked at being
able to generate a model that allows you
to predict a revenue now a lot of times
when you're studying machine learning
and you get into deep learning or any of
the other models almost all of them have
some math based on this linear
regression model this is the basis of so
much and if you're starting with any new
data this is a good place to start
because it helps build very solid
function you can look at and usually can
predict a lot of things or you can take
this prediction and put it into your
next step which would be to look for
outliers things that don't match the
linear regression model and find out why
and find out other information about
those areas so you can better predict
them in which case we'll wrap up our
linear regression model in our today
thank you for joining us for more
information visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here